the covet 19 lockdowns have upended no
part of our lives more than k-12
education with virtually
no public schools open for business with
full-time
in-person instruction the result is
pandemonium for
students parents and educators alike who
are scrambling to make sense of school
systems that are no longer capable of
fulfilling their missions
the one constant critiques of school
choice
especially by wealthy well-connected
liberals and progressives
private and charter schools can be
especially problematic because some
states have
virtually no oversight for them as a
matter of fact samantha b
is wrong about charter schools which are
publicly funded and
always overseen by either state or local
education officials
she's joined in her contempt for
charters by joe biden who came out
swinging in an interview with the
national education association the
nation's largest teachers union
a lot of these charter schools are
significantly underperforming
significantly and it's not even clear
that school choice
leads to a better education the latest
meta analysis that i've seen on the
evidence for
charter schools is by julian betts and
emily tang
and they found that overall looking at
the most rigorous evidence looking at
you know random assignment gold standard
evaluations and other
evaluations that try to make it as
apples to apples as possible when
looking at these comparisons
they conclude that there's about a two
to three percent standard deviation
increase in academic outcomes corey
deangelis is the director of school
choice for the reason foundation
and co-editor of the new collection
school choice myths
setting the record straight on education
reform deangelis who holds a phd in
education from university of arkansas
says widespread dissatisfaction with
online education
is massively increasing interest in
school choice
the school system has gotten so bad that
families are figuring out
that there's no good reason to fund
institutions when you can fund students
directly instead
people are re-envisioning the factory
model of schooling itself because a lot
of people are getting a taste of
homeschooling another thing that people
are re-envisioning is how we finance
education so many of the schools aren't
even opening the system's still getting
your child's education dollars even
though they're not reopening whereas if
you're
a family on food stamps and your
neighborhood grocery store doesn't
reopen they don't get to keep your food
stamps
families are turning towards the idea
that the funding should follow the
student to wherever they're getting an
education
deangelis points to a poll showing that
17
of parents who have disenrolled their
children from traditional public schools
this fall
wouldn't go back even if the schools
reopened for in-person instruction
and that charter school operators in
states such as south carolina are
expecting a 40
increase in the size of their student
bodies in the coming year
if the charter schools aren't
accountable to families why are 3.2
million families choosing charter
schools
each and every year families can take
their children elsewhere if the charter
schools aren't doing a good job
deangelis points to a recent study of
low-income minority students in boston
who attended charters
they found pretty large increases in
10th grade
academic proficiencies on their state
exam
and then also higher enrollments in
college as well
the findings were overall positive for
students with special needs that won a
lottery to attend a charter and then
also
students that were identified as english
language learner students
deangelis says there's no turning back
when it comes to school choice
if your grocery store doesn't reopen you
can take your money elsewhere if your
child's school doesn't reopen you should
similarly be able to take your
children's education dollars elsewhere
when you look at all these other
taxpayer-funded initiatives that the
funding follows the person
it doesn't go to the institution
regardless of how well it meets your
needs
i think more people are seeing this
issue with how we finance
k-12 education